Francois Malley aware was born in Paris
in 1694 his father a well-established
lawyer sent him to the best school in
the capital and by all accounts he was a
brilliant student
the young AAHA we're decided at an early
age to make his name as a writer or
rather to remake his name as the first
thing he did was to change this name to
Voltaire the 18th century is often
referred to as the age of reason or the
age of enlightenment but sometimes more
fairly simply as the age of Voltaire so
changing his name was a good call the
age of our wear would just not have
worked quite as well Voltaire was
precociously talented as a poet at the
age of only 24 he had his first verse
tragedy performed at the Comedie
Francaise
by then he'd already begun work on an
epic poem about the French religious
civil wars of the 16th century
glorifying Henry the fourth as the king
who brought peace by pragmatically
converting from Protestantism to
Catholicism this was to be a subject
dear to volt as heart for under the
guise of writing a national epic he was
dwelling at length on the bloody
consequences of religious intolerance
right from the start
Voltaire's views on religion were
expressed robustly he was not an atheist
in part because he thought that some
minimal belief in a deity was useful for
social cohesion volquez God had created
the world instilled in us a sense of
good and evil and then basically taken a
back seat this was known as rational
religion or in the 18th century called
natural religion or deism
and it had no truck with metaphysics of
any kind Voltaire was basically a man of
reason who loathed fanaticism idolatry
and superstition that men can kill each
other to defend some bit of religious
doctrine which they scarcely understand
is something he found repellent and he
reserved his greatest hatred for the
clerics who exploited the credulity of
believers to maintain their own power
base Voltaire wanted religion
but not the church for obvious reasons
the Catholic authorities were not keen
for Voltaire's poem about Henry the
fourth LA okie odd to be published in
France so Voltaire decided to go and
publish it in London instead and in 1726
went and traveled to England what began
as a business trip soon turned however
into something quite different and
Voltaire ended up staying in England for
some two and a half years he learned to
speak English fluently got to know
writers and politicians and became a
great admirer of English Protestant
culture he decided to write a book about
his experience of England and the
letters concerning the English nation
appeared first in English in 1733 the
French authorities were horrified the
book was censored and Volta only
narrowly avoided prison that's because
the book presented an informal portrait
of English culture in a witty and
ironical style looking intern at
religion politics science and literature
in ways that were critical implicitly of
French culture and politics here for
example is how Voltaire presents the
Royal Exchange a handsome building in
the heart of the City of London where
merchants from across the world would
meet to transact business take a view of
the Royal Exchange Voltaire Road where
the representatives of all nations meet
for the benefit of mankind there the Jew
the and a Christian transact
together as though they all profess the
same religion and give the name of
infidel to none but bankrupts there the
Presbyterian confides in the Anabaptist
and the churchmen depends on the Quakers
word at the breaking up of this Pacific
and free assembly some will withdraw to
the synagogue and others to take a glass
this man goes and is baptized in a great
tub in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Ghost
that man has his son's foreskin cut off
while a set of Hebrew words quite
unintelligible to him a mumbled over his
child if one religion only were allowed
in England the government would very
possibly become arbitrary if there were
but to the people would cut one
another's throats but as there are such
a multitude they all live happy and in
peace Valdez message is clear religious
differences are trivial and separate
men while trade is important and brings
them together his conclusion that the
plurality of religions in England leads
to a more peaceful society is of course
a covert criticism of France where the
Catholic Church was so dominant the
letters concerning the English nation
also discussed Locke and Newton thinkers
then poorly known in France the subject
matter might seem challenging but
Voltaire is a past master at
popularizing difficult material ask any
school child today what they know about
Newton and they'll tell you about the
Apple falling on his head and the
survival of this anecdote is due
entirely to Voltaire he heard it from
Newton's nice and immediately understood
that this simple homely image was the
perfect way of conveying the simplicity
of Newton's explanation of the force of
gravity after Voltaire used the story in
his letters concerning the English
nation everyone remembered it and
Voltaire left his mark on English
popular culture Voltaire struggled with
a question of good and evil the problem
at the heart of his best-known work
Candide which was published in 1759 and
was a best-seller from the moment it
appeared translated into every possible
language it remains the most widely read
work of the European enlightenment it's
even left its mark on our language
expressions like poor aqua has really
sought to encourage the others or ill
fukuchi village' hada we must cultivate
our garden have entered common usage in
the best of all possible worlds yes
that's another one speakers of French or
English quote Candide without even
realizing it and that's the shore mark
of a classic Candide is a timeless work
a satire of the human condition but it's
also a work of the Enlightenment and its
philosophical theme is announced in the
title Candide or optimism the hero of
Candide as his name tells us is an
innocent antihero he is enthralled to
his tutor Pangloss who preaches the
philosophy of optimism this is not
optimism in the modern sense of looking
on the bright side
optimism spelt with a capital o and is
expounded by the German philosopher
lighten it's was an attempt to answer
the age-old problem of evil
why if God is good does he permit the
existence of evil in the
world to which the 18th century live
knit see an optimist replies evil is all
part of some greater pattern of good all
partial evil universal good as the
English poet Pope put it in other words
evil doesn't really exist at all
it's just something which man imagines
because of his limited view of the world
you might think this sounds like a bit
of a confidence trick and voltar
certainly did but this idea did find
widespread acceptance in the 18th
century Kant deeds great mission was to
put this philosophy to the test
ejected from his comfortable home in an
obscure German castle after trying to
seduce the Barons beautiful daughter
Cunegonde Voltaire xerocon deed
undergoes many trials and tribulations
conscripted into the army he fights in a
war then deserts only to find himself a
witness to an earthquake in Lisbon
Candide is repeatedly brought face to
face with evil in its most extreme forms
moral evil in the case of the earthquake
where man is not apparently to blame and
most of all human evil such as a war
where man is very definitely to blame
Paul glosses breezy optimism it's
clearly an inadequate response to
enormities of evil on this scale
eventually even khan deed comes to
realise this to quote from the book and
sometimes Punk loss would say to Candide
all events form a chain in the best of
all possible worlds for in the end if
you'd not been given a good kick up the
bat side and chased out of a beautiful
castle for loving miss Cunegonde and if
you hadn't been subjected to the
Inquisition and if you hadn't wandered
about America on foot and if you hadn't
dealt the Baron a good blow with your
sword and if you hadn't lost all your
sheep from that fine country of Eldorado
you wouldn't be here now eating candied
citron and pistachio nuts that is well
put replied Candide but we must
cultivate our garden after 1760 Voltaire
took up residence in a chateau at fair
knee just outside Geneva by now he was
the most famous living writer in Europe
and he became widely known as the
patriarch of fairnie he took up a number
of public causes in 1761 a Protestant
merchant Jacques Kallis was accused of
murdering his son and sentenced by the
judges of Toulouse to be tortured and
then broken on the wheel the legal
processes were to say
least irregular and the suspicion grew
that the judges in his Catholic City had
acted with excessive zeal out of
religious bigotry a Voltaire became
involved in the case and mounted an
energetic campaign to rehabilitate
calluses memory and help the members of
his family who'd been left destitute he
wrote letters to those in authority and
published a stream of pamphlets
culminating in 1763 in his pretty solid
belly house which begins with the
historical facts of the Calais case and
broadens out into a history of religious
intolerance in European culture
Valdez writings had enormous impact on
public opinion and eventually the judges
in Paris quashed the judgment of the
toulouse court too late to save Calais
but a huge victory for Voltaire who'd
learned an important lesson about how
change could be brought about through
the pressure of public opinion opinion
rules the world he wrote in 1764 but in
the long run it's the philosophers who
shape this opinion Voltaire said of
himself that he wrote to act and he
wanted his writings to change the way
people thought and behaved in leading
his Crusades against fanaticism he even
invented a campaign slogan it caused a
love thumb which translates roughly as
crushed the despicable Lapham stands
here for everything that Voltaire hated
everything that he had spent his life
fighting superstition intolerance
irrational behavior of every kind we
should never forget that Voltaire was
also a brilliant writer one of the
greatest stylists the French language
has ever known the power of his ideas
had a lot to do with the power of his
expression many writers made fun of
miracles
no one did so as hilariously as Voltaire
always Voltaire had an ear for the
telling phrase if God had not existed it
would have been necessary to invent him
it's a good line even in English and
better still in the original French
where it's more memorable because it's a
classical Alexandrian line in 12
syllables see jus Nixie stepper Ilford
well Avanti Volt has legacy in our
present debates about religious
toleration
remain extremely potent hardly a week
passes without an article in the press
quoting I disapprove of what you say but
I
we'll defend to the death your right to
say it this rallying cry of tolerant
multiculturalism is so potent that if
Voltaire hadn't said it we would have
had to invent it which is what happened
the expression was invented by an
English woman in 1906 no matter it
expresses a truth which is fundamentally
important to our culture so we have
adopted the phrase and decided that
Voltaire said it
Valdez name has become synonymous with a
set of liberal values freedom of speech
rejection of bigotry and superstition
belief in reason and tolerance it's a
unique and nowadays extremely precious
legacy
you